so hello
thanks thanks a lot i will have a
quick setup here but yeah it's really
nice that you're all here at this time
last large session of the day probably
later there will be the
um
[Music]
the
[Music]
the keynote right
um
so
i can only see that on one screen that's
a bit funny so
that's good right
[Music]
so
yeah so hello
glad you're all interested in ml ops and
getting hands-on with mlflow
yeah and to be a sterbuck as simon said
i'm an nlp freelancer doing doing all
kinds of stuff machine learning data
science mostly with text
nowadays also it's more nlp like
becoming more nlp and machine learning
engineering also
so that's why also this talk came to be
kind of
i gave a similar tutorial in 2019 but
some things changed since then on the
amber flow
stack so i thought i'd do it again and
it was quite quite nice last time
and i hope it will give you some
insights in ml flow what is ml ops what
you can do some overview maybe if you
are familiar with mlflow close some gaps
you see some new things
or
see what other people might do with
mlflow um
yeah so you can find me on the website
call to bear starbucks.com i have a blog
with mostly nlp data science stuff
depends on the definition
dot com you can tweet it to be a
starbuck
and i have a github where also
the notebooks and the material for the
talk is the slides are not there yet and
probably never will because they are not
super great and
will not be useful without me talking
probably most of the content will be on
the blog
in the following weeks
yeah so i have to block here because
later we just do hands-on stuff
um
yeah so
before we begin i have some questions
for you quickly to to check what's going
on in the crowd um
who have you
raised hands please
train the machine learning model before
something
so that's basically everyone
i guess so
kind of
and now next question who have you
tracked or like used excel sheets google
sheets or something to keep track of
results of
machine learning experiments and stuff
okay so a few so that would be
interesting okay so the following
question
who didn't keep track of machine
learning experiment results at all or
just like dumped some files somewhere
okay so some people are honest
cool
and then
last question like who is familiar with
some tracking solutions for machine
learning experience i used them for
okay so also a few people so i'm
wondering what is what is the the
leftover people but we will figure out
so
today we i will try to answer basically
all of these questions
um and said like amberflow might be a
solution for stuff at a certain point
in your machine learning
majority journey in the company and the
problem you're working on
um
sometimes it's not the right tool
sometimes it's not yet the right tool
and sometimes it never will be the right
tool
um so
yeah let's have a look at the uh agenda
for today so first i will give you a
brief introduction on
mlops what are the goals what are the
ideas
really really brief
um
then give you a short high level
overview over mlflow what are the
different components and what are they
used for
and then basically
we will
only do hands-on stuff from there on and
i try to
show you basic not super basic setup of
ammo flow for tracking experiments
and having a tracking server
and keeping track of what's going on
and then
we go into how to manage artifacts like
models from these experiments these
machine learning experiments and how to
deploy them with ml flow and keep track
of the state
of the resulting models and then if we
have time in the end
we probably skipped this but the
material will be online
tips and tricks like what kind of stuff
might be interesting for you at a
certain point
and might be might be useful
to achieve certain
outcomes so
so
what's envelops and why should you even
care
and so basically mlab stands for machine
learning operation management or machine
learning operation operalization hard
work
um
and
it's basically
and
i mean and nobody really agrees it's not
i guess it's less agreed on what it
means than devops and that's even a hot
topic what that means
so it's basically a set of tools right
to
[Music]
to
bring machine learning to production
that's basically what it's focusing on
it's focusing on taking machine learning
models to production
maintaining them monitoring them and
stay sane in the process basically
and
it
tries to reduce the technical depth
in doing that
so you want to be as lazy as possible to
achieve
and reduce the bus factor basically
be fast and
know where you left off last month
basically it's important for me as a
freelancer right because if i'm coming
back after a month or if like i'm
um
i need to know what happened and that's
that's um
interesting requirement
and then life cycle management so you
want to keep track
of your release cycle you want to know
which models are
used at what time how they came to be
what data were used what parameters were
used and you want to be able to
reproduce that also for govern
governance reasons right when someone
says like someone something went wrong
um
i probably need to need to be able to
track down what happened and where where
this model and
came from basically so that's a really
high level envelopes
overview and i mean there might be
might be other ideas and other
definitions
um
yeah
so
and to to see where this fits in the
machine learning life cycle
i i give you a brief overview also there
what i understand
on machine learning life cycle and i
mean the material is by data breaks
um
or at least this this picture
and uh yeah
and
basically you start with data right on
the left hand side and then
obviously
normally followed by some exploratory
data analysis you look at the data you
you try to figure out what is actually
the machine learning problem you want to
solve you need to solve what are metrics
what is what is
going on in your data
then there usually comes data
preparation data selection feature
engineering step
um
and of course i mean there are these
arrows going in one direction but
usually they go all the way all over the
place
um
but we call it life cycle because it's a
nice cycle then but uh
usually it's not directed at cyclic
graph
and then we come to model training and
find tunic or tuning the model
there's a bunch of tools available for
that and then once you have a model or
you settled for a model and specific
configurations you probably do model
review and need to consult people for
for model governance to check
that the model behaves in certain ways
beyond probably your machine learning
metrics
and next step is you package your model
for inference and serving
um and then
followed by deploying and hopefully
monitoring
and then we have at a certain point in
time probably a retraining step in the
ideal case it's automated i mean here's
automated model retraining because
databricks
has a has a platform for machine
learning
i'm not affiliated with them in any way
by the way so they
like databricks the company built this
open source tool ammo flow
that i like to use but i'm not
affiliated with them and it's open
source so you can use it
um yeah and as i said usually you go
back somewhere in the process and start
from different points
and what we see today basically is with
model training
we try to collect information to have
the model review and governance in place
and can
we can work there
and we see how to package the stuff and
run inference under models and then how
to deploy from a centralized
infrastructure basically
i would love to show all the monitoring
but
i have no idea how to do that in a
structured way it's so from my
perspective so problem dependent but
it's super important so don't forget
this and it's super important in your ml
ops
envelopes part um
but yeah
maybe there will be a tutorial on this
in the future
um so
that was amalops now mlflow
and as i probably said
mflow is an open source platform to
manage your machine learning life cycle
so
you can host it yourself
run the take the parts you need and
build some kind of machine learning
platform around it
it has
so far four components for main
components
that we will look into
first component is tracking it's
basically
an api and a storage format and a ui
to record and
query and keep track of experiments of
machine learning experiments and collect
all the relevant information to these
experiments
then there's projects we won't look into
that too much but
that's basically a packaging format to
reproduce
models with
docker with conda or something so you
can just package everything together and
someone else running it with this
same data with a simple command gets the
same model
on a different machine optimally
i never found that too particularly
useful to be honest so
yeah we won't look into that too much
and then there's models
which is basically a
specific
general format to describe the
model you want to use and how how
what needs to be done to deploy it so
it's a flexible
format to manage deployments of models
and we also will use that
and then finally and i find quite
interesting and quite important here
it's the model registry
which is basically
um
also ui and the format to
[Music]
manage the model life cycle
to keep track of state of the model to
deploy from there and um to
yeah keep track of the model lineage
basically exactly where did it come from
um and what happened to the model
downstream like when did it move to
production when was it archived was it
on staging at some point you can you can
add features to that even we probably
will see that too
um
[Music]
so that was basically the short
introduction so
time-wise that's fine so at this point
any short
questions
i mean it was just just high-level
overview
okay perfect
so everyone's happy or confused or both
um
so for the hands-on part i will switch
to jupyter notebooks
you can find the notebooks on
this github link
and there will be also some annoying
installation instructions
to get it running
i will now try to switch there
so
this is
this somewhat readable in the back
i can zoom a bit probably if i can
figure out how
um
so
so basically so this is like
so what we need is we need a within the
sqli database and
i'm sorry so like this is linux i wrote
linux but it's of course only debian
based i guess
so sorry for that and for your windows i
have absolutely no idea what to do
and for mac it already should be
installed
i was told
so we need sqlite that's a requirement
to deploy models from from the registry
and then there's iris
settle for pipelines here so piping is
the way to go other than that i mean if
you want
there is also
it's basically four packages right so
amaflo is installable with
pip so you can just create whatever
environment you like and pick these four
packages jupiter panda circuit learn and
demo flow
cool
so
then if you have megan installed you
could also just run make notebook but
we can just do
run
to notebook
and then it will open it probably
in some very crowded browser that i
don't want to use
um
and we go to
to the chromium
and
look at this there so
i can also zoom zoom zoom zoom
this is somewhat readable
i mean it's a jupyter notebook so
um add a jupyter notebook whatever
landing page
um
and then in the
tutorial so i might be a bit faster
sometimes but there will be breaks and
exercises so
i i start with the first part of the
notebook and then i
have some small exercise and go around
and check
if everything works out so far
sorry
cool
thanks for the
um comment so yeah so this is the first
notebook um
run track experiments
um
[Music]
there we will see how to set up the
ember flow tracking server the ui how to
interact with the ui and how to actually
run experiments and track them in
um
in the mflow with the tracking server
so first of course i wanted some
penguins in the
in the presentation so
we were gonna use the the
um primal penguins data set which is
basically a simple classification data
set as a drop-in replacement for the
iris data set where you want to classify
three types of penguins
by their
bill length or how's it called the
kalman measurements so we have basically
two
features two megahertz features and um
we want to classify into these three
categories of penguins
yeah the data set should also be
included in the repository if you clone
the repository you have the data set
and
let's see if that all that stuff works
so we can load the data set
with pandas so we see there's some
measurements and some
labels
for those
then we do
simple
or like the the usual machine learning
steps we do a trend test split
we have psychic
learn we pick some classifier picked
your decision to classifier
you could later change it if you want um
yeah with two
i mean it's a bit obvious to change any
parameters here but
so we get
yeah and then we evaluate and get some
some
accuracy score for the classifier
um so that's so that's where we where we
are right you you started a machine
learning project you you played around
you got the first metric now what what
to do
if you if you want to iterate on that
and that's where basically amaflo
tracking comes in
and i probably ask at this point
is for
for whom
who wants to run the notebooks are they
running now
so it is someone
trying to run them but needs a minute
longer or something
okay so
then we wait for a second
but otherwise it looks good so that's
good i'm happy
okay
so i just move on because now it's a bit
more talking again
ah sorry i i'm not sure if i understood
but i guess the question was like if we
can see the python modules again
i mean i used 3.9
the question was if there's a
requirement for a specific python
version i used 3.99 here but i guess
everything over 3.7 should be fine
but it
it's not fine
i'm not sure
i can come back to you in a second yeah
ah it doesn't work with 3.8 so then we
have 3.9
okay then sorry
okay so there should be a log file there
so
if you install from the from the
repository it should then work i guess i
tested with 3.7 even i'm not sure
well
okay
minor setup issues i'm sorry for that
um i can try to come around in an
exercise break and we can see if i can
fix it or we can fix it
um
now it's again a bit of a theoretical um
section here
which is basically um the introduction
to the tracking stores and the artifact
stores so emma flow
tracking is basically composed of two
components which is basically a tracking
store which tracks all the metrics
parameters all kinds of one of stuff you
want to track
at some place so there's a default path
that can be a local local file path
where it would just dump everything for
one experiment in a file
or you could use
all kinds of relational databases mysql
sql sqlite postgres basically everything
that sql alchemy
supports
you could use an as an http server that
that
listens to
or that has the end of flow tracking
server running
and of course you can use the databricks
workspace whatever
that does
so that's the one one side where you
track the information of the experiment
and then there's the other part which is
the artifact store where you store all
the models the artifacts plots
i like to store all the source code
there for example for every run um
like that's where you saw all the hard
heavy stuff basically you could store
their data sets if you if you like um
and that space could be also local file
path
or
like something like the amazon s3 azure
blob search google cloud search and all
kinds of other
file system like things where you can
um dump files
um
and so
we we go for um
like a
medium
heavy
setup which is basically uh
this does not even fit in the whole
picture here
um so what i mean if you have the
notebooks or you can look at github
on the github in the notebook then you
see this picture
properly so we we use for artifacts we
use a local file path which we called we
called ml runs
and for um
as the
as the
tracking storage that's called here
tracking storage we use the sqlite
database
um
mainly the main reason for that is for
deployment for some reason which i'm not
sure what this is and the floor requires
you to use a database and not a local
file path but i guess it's because even
even with this setup it's a bit annoying
with the file paths because they're
probably not absolute and then sometimes
things can get messed up so
um yeah we use a database to track the
experiments
and that's kind of how it looks like so
we have an mlflow user code the client
api
and then two two storage repositories
dml runs for the artifacts and a
database to store all
all associated information to that
experiment
and now
you need a terminal
and
you can run
basically this command which is
basically uses the mlflow
cli tool
to start a server at this sqlite
database and or it will create it if
it's not there yet and the artifact root
especially the artifact storage that
will be emma runs and then it will run
the server on localhost with port 5000.
i would recommend running this in the
tutorial directory and not in the root
of the repository just because then it
works easier with the
max notebook
and you probably need to run
pip and run or check out your
environment or something
so
i will move to a
terminal
and we do
okay wait i of course want to copy this
and pip
and run
so i paste it in and try to zoom a bit
so like this
and now we see like there's our alarm
brick running that's the creating the
database and the migrations for the for
the database
um and probably it was already stupid
because i
didn't do what i said
so
um
let's remove this again so i mean and if
you if you mess up anything in this in
this tutorial you just delete these two
files like the ama flow db
and
um
the ml runs
on the runs directory and then
everything mflow did to your environment
and your
stuff is gone so let's check our
tutorial
and then run this again
so now we see we have
the server running
and
we can now
open this
logos port 5000 in the browser
and then we should see the ammo flow
tracking ui
and says yeah you can track some stuff
now
and run experiments
um
[Music]
so
the question is who arrived there so far
okay that's probably
50 percent
uh
okay
i'm sorry about that so
so who is in the process of still trying
to start it and
still has not given up
okay so so one one issue that
occurred so far and possible solution so
issue was
the the
required server wasn't starting up and
one solution could be changed a port
from 5000 to something else did it work
so that was one solution that worked
um cool so
now you have the amateur tracking server
running at crea you can check in your
file system that created the database
and the mlrants directory to store the
artifacts
and now we can conveniently go back to
the
to the notebook
um
import ml flow
and
the built-in
mflow circuit learn tools i forgot to
mention that
so ammo flow comes with a bunch a large
bunch of built-in tools to track
and um
like yeah keep track of
existing machine learning libraries like
for example scikit-learn and they call
it flavors and that
provides like a super easy access to all
kinds of stuff
related to these libraries and to
tracking and deployment and they even
have functionality for some for example
for scikit-learn for auto logging where
you really don't have to do anything
other than call autolog
and then it locks whatever it thinks is
appropriate to log for a second learn
model
we don't do it here for
different reasons because they are more
flexible if you know how it works under
the hood um
and
i never used auto logging so i feel a
bit weird to tell you about it um
good so we use the scikit-learn flavor
here
to make our lives a bit easier
then we set
the remote
server
like we point basically our tracking
server
um or like yeah we we put our tracking
server um address here
and let emflo know where we want to
track this is especially important right
if you if you have a distributed server
server somewhere in the cloud where you
want to lock your experiments for
example as a team or so
all right so here we set it to the log
close port 5000 and now we can verify
yeah it's actually
set
yeah
next step is we we create an experiment
we give it a name and then we call them
a flow create experiment
um
this is like the explicit step you could
also just check out the experiment
but like i like to keep that explicit
here
you can also create an experiment in the
ui
you see
here some experiments right now it's
only the default experiment you could
add experiment here
but that's probably something you don't
want to do
so the question was if if amber flow is
compatible with some windows
so sadly i have no idea
i haven't found any windows users to
test it also so i don't know
but in theory it should work if python
works
but maybe maybe someone in the audience
knows
um
yeah with window windows i'm sadly not
helpful
um sorry about that
so
okay moving on um
so
now now we have we've seen in the
beginning that the the basic machine
learning stuff we want to track
yeah we want to run and now we are
presented with the
opportunity to track that stuff
and there are two basic things that
mlflow
wants you to track or you probably want
to track and one is parameters which is
all kind of configuration stuff for your
model like you would the depth of your
trees or the number of data points or
something like this
which you can use emma flow log
parameter
if you want to store so
yeah the log param takes key value pairs
and the log params takes the dictionary
and logs in multiple at the same time
and
for metrics which is basically things
you want to compare and
and check compare your models on you
you
can use log metrics and log metric
we will see later how that is different
in the ui
so as you remember i mean or as a
remember
um yeah we this is the code we had
before
right and then now we add
to this to this machine learning code we
add the ammo flow tracking code
first here we have to set the experiment
like tell them a flow where it should
track the stuff in the ui
so we see you have here
i you probably have to refresh right
so we see we have here a second
experiment that's called penguin
classification which is currently empty
has the id number one
okay
so we set the experiment here
for the run and then we start to run as
a in with this context manager
and so it says ember flows.run and then
you can pick s run this is not directly
required but i like it so you can have
some output on the run
like for example you get the run id
which is
the central information pop like the
central piece of information you need
to know which kind of experiment you're
talking about
like like your git hash
for commit or something
so
then then we just load the data set as
usual
do the train test split
and then here we start logging the
parameters for our decision tree
classifier so we basically call them a
flow log params
with the dictionary
with the name of the parameter and its
value
and then we trade then we
instantiate the classifier and train it
um and at the end we lock our test
accuracy within the flow log metric
so if i run this now i mean you see the
output here now because i didn't clean
it but then you see okay this is the the
custom output i put there and
if we
[Music]
if we go and refresh
the ui
we see okay there's now one run recorded
it's coming from a jupiter ipython
kernel
i created it and this is the output and
we see here it differentiates between
metrics and parameters
and
if we click here we can also go
and see the specific information of this
run
after run id
duration
[Music]
certain certain information life cycle
stage
you can add a description here
and here we see the parameters
metrics text and artifacts so currently
we have no artifacts recorded that will
change soon
um and we have here test accuracy that
we can compare that we also do later
once we have more stuff to compare
good
so
and now when i come to the first
exercise
track some more stuff right so right now
we did the basic of the basics
um but you could track of course more
stuff like git versions
um i got code versions start my end time
sometimes it's also it's also part of
emma flow already i like to track the
source code like if i have a strip strip
script
producing the model i like to just all
my the library to create the model i
like to lock all the source codes you
can just copy it to s3 and it usually
doesn't matter if you dump a few more
kilobytes
on s3 if you know in the end this is the
exact exact code
i mean
git commit hash is also nice but usually
i'm not committing
every different machine learning
experiment i run because if i only
change some parameters or something
or some small stuff then i'm not sure if
it works and otherwise my commit history
is completely crowded with stupid
minor changes to model parameters that i
probably don't want to have in my code
right
depends so
properties of the input data is probably
something you want to track plots
and model artifacts
um like the output of a model
so
so what you could track now for example
is
like examples here is one of the
properties of the input data like the
shape or the number of samples or how
the split is done or something
um or you could track the whole notebook
source code
right and but for this ember flow has a
specific
function which is called log artifact
which takes a file path
local path basically and puts it to the
artifact storage
but it could load it up to a google blob
storage or s3 or whatever file path you
specify
so
yeah so here in this exercise cell you
find the code from above you can modify
now
and probably track some some more runs
right and i
how long do we have
probably
five to ten minutes
and i walk around and answer some
questions
and then we can
move on
so
cool so
some problems some problems were solved
everyone basically resolved them
themselves so
cool
so
let's let's move on you had some
fun with tracking some different stuff
one one thing that was pointed out to me
and one question i had
uh someone had was
if you can track for example environment
variables because there are different
ways right how you would pass
information to your script
and yeah sure you can i mean you can
track everything to the parameter store
that you can access as a python string
or python whatever
and you can track everything and log
everything to the artifact store that
you can access in the local file system
so
here here's this possible solution and
we see how to log for example a file a
local file in this case the notebook
itself
so first quick like here is the
number of samples
logged as a parameter
could also be locked as a metric depends
on how you want to use it
i keep it as a parameter here
and then the second thing
i suggested was you could lock the
notebook so here we just point to the
notebook i mean this is a
path it's in the same directory so it's
not super exciting but you could also
lock the whole
code directory for example
and if we run that
we see okay same output
but in the repository
i need to get back here here
i'll get rid of this
we see
[Music]
there is
no artifacts
no artifacts
thanks yeah good point
um so here yeah in the artifacts there's
now the
um
the notebook itself and you could put it
in a deeper direction directory if you
want so there's different options
where you can put that
um
so and now now the the important part
basically or one of the important parts
is like how to lock the model
um
so
we of course want to use the model
artifact later probably and we want to
go back to it and we want to deploy it
and we want to keep track what it is
actually
um and
since we use the scikit-learn model here
the things are quite um nice but it's
also there for pi torch for tensorflow
for cameras for xg boost for whatever
there's inbuilt flavors as i said and
here we use the emma flow circuit learn
log model and you just pass the model
here's it it's called tree and give it a
name so that it's
that's basically the directory where
it's put on
at the mflow artifact store
and then
we can put this at the end
of our
script
so here's the log
mflow.psycitlearn.log model
and then if we run that
looks the same
[Music]
and we see
as our first thing we see is here we see
a model
with the
name of the flavor in this case but
could be also custom thing
and we see here this is in the artifact
now the models directory appeared that
contains
different
like different things to reproduce the
model
and
specifies how the model
um
what the model is like in a model ml
models file for example you see
description of dependencies and
different information
conda contact environment requirements
pip environment
specification and then there's a model
pickle to
basically get a model back
so now
i have another small exercise but i
guess most of you already did it
um
but run run this code with different
parameters so i will quickly do that and
you can also if you want but we won't do
it longer than i need to and i
it takes me to do it so we create
different
different outputs here let's say this
some of them are stupid
so this is probably not
good this is good
so we create a few things that we can
compare something
so
okay
so if we go now to the ui
ah i'm always confused so there's now a
few more runs we see here also failed
runs
now because i failed to run them
properly and now we can select for
example here we want to compare them
right
um so we can select this
select these four runs because they were
successful they have a model
and then i mean if you're only
interested in test accuracy nice you can
look here and say like oh well this is
the best one i'm happy
but you could also
compare them and see like how
get different different plots to to
inspect the model based on parameters
like here's the
parallel coordinates plot you can get a
scatter plot
depth versus accuracy for example
probably other way around
depends yeah
[Music]
or
you can see the run specifically and how
the parameters affect
performance
and the metrics
so and here you could jump directly to
the specific runs and see the details of
the run
so
yeah
feel free to play with that
good compare models in the ui done yeah
sorry i have a question i tried to store
data.described the result of that it was
described which is a data frame and
failed
is there a possibility
so so the question was
um can we can we store
the result of data frame described like
pandas data frame describe
and
yes you can
you cannot store it so so the log
paragrams log metrics take only key
value pairs
of simple i mean simple types probably
hard but like simple types like numbers
or strings
but not data frames
so what you can do is you can write it
to file
and then store the file which is usually
what i would do like if you do like
create classification report with
psychic learn or something would write
that to file and store it and then it
would appear here in the
in the artifacts
as
as a file that you can read like this
right and it can look here and see like
well but it's hard to compare then
i
so
if you want specific information you i
would recommend logging it as a
parameter or a metric
um but if you say like okay i have a
model i have long classification report
different details i want to load plots
specific plots and i would lock them as
files
cool
so i mean optional but i guess we will
do it how long do i have actually
how long how long is it still
okay 25 minutes is cool good 25 minutes
should be fine then we do that
so
um signature which is basically an api
api um
also called i forgot um
api schema
that that you can attach to your model
that is important and interesting later
in deployment
so if we look for example at the current
model here it says like well here's no
model schema
set
so
um
what we can do and i mean i just give
you here to code it's
so you could also do that if you want so
we import the relevant stuff model
signature and the schema and then we can
specify every input column as a schema
we expect double here and we give it a
name
we specify output schema we output
strings
and then we create a model signature
from that
model signature from that and that can
be passed here to the log
log model as
signature um and actually if you deploy
that later cycle
mlflow
will enforce this this schema otherwise
it will fail internally if you pass
something else right but if you have a
schema in place and it will be enforced
note but note that different
different deployment or different
i'd say deployment tools like sagemaker
or google cloud or something they might
not enforce it in a way like you expect
or sometimes don't expose it i don't
enforce it properly
given
given the runtime yeah so
run this and now if we refresh here
we see
another model
and now
this has a schema here that says this
okay this is what i expect this is the
output i
expect it didn't give the output a name
that's probably bad you should give it a
name
um
good
and now now what we finally can do is
like
to simply test the model and references
from the experiment log even is like we
we can depl like run it locally like we
retrieve it from the artifact store and
the
tracking server
and so actually i mean it will talk to
the tracking server and the tracking
server knows where the artifacts are
stores brings everything together and
loads it locally
which can also be a first step of
deployment depending on how you
how you like to work with it but here
this is how you would reference
different runs in mflow so this is
runs
column and then this is the run id
and this is the name of
the model or basically the directory in
the artifact store of that specific run
so
for example here it would be this id
right i need to get some id now because
the id in the notebook is obviously old
so i need this one
and then i know it's called model here
so i go here say okay this is what i
want
it loads the model and then we run some
tests the same test data basically again
and we see okay we get some
output
cool
so
that's part part one
now tracking is up and running
and the flow is probably
properly
starting to fill up with stuff
and now we want to move to the second
notebook
and
see how to deploy and keep track a bit
of the
state
so
as we saw before i know someone
was talking about is emma flow models is
basically a specification of how the
model can be packaged and reproduced and
run
and
the built-in deployment and serving
tools of mflow basically reference this
format and put together environments
so you can run your model basically
basically everywhere
hard to say but um
yeah so you can for example push it to
sagemaker push it to an apache spark
cluster push it to kubernetes with a
docker container
do different stuff push push it to azure
ml
um
and
airflow makes it quite easy
we will not do most of the things now
because probably there's no sagemaker or
kubernetes available
at least yeah not for this tutorial um
so basically the format is this kind of
yaml
format in the in the models repository
in the mod directory that specifies the
the flavors so the cycle that we can
deploy it as a
psychic learn flavor and and the lace
adjective
the lowest possible flavor is the python
functions flavor which can could
basically run everything that is a
python function
so
i probably put this in here now
so you can write your custom models
there
and
and i'd like to do that you can put all
your preprocessing in there and track
this also with mflow and then you would
deploy it as a python function of of
course and you can
deploy any kind of python function with
this functionality um
yeah so and
the simplest way to
deploy as a http
local
uh rest server
is basically with amazflo models
serve and then point to the model
um i'll show you in a second the proper
proper command
um
so we talked about amberflow models and
that now we talk about a model registry
which is probably you noticed another
part of the ui
and now there's a bit of confusion so
the model registry is basically
a component as a centralized model story
like you
have a set of apis a ui and some
conventions to manage the life cycle of
an mflo model that becomes mostly
interesting once you have at least a
small team but also for a single
single person project it might be
interesting to know what happened in the
past to your stuff
yeah it provides model lineage
and
tells you like which experiment and
which run letters are modeled and what
happened to that model right
model versioning stage transition
for example from
to staging to production to some archive
or to delete it even
and you have another set of annotations
available
there's a bit of confusion here because
there's like the model which is the
model
as an ammo flow model and then there's a
registered model which is a model that
is registered in the model registry but
will be also called model
okay but we will see the difference i
guess so
um
and they're dif and how to register this
um
right i should do probably
this for
yeah
[Music]
so we start again by by setting up
and pointing to the to the tracking
server
and now we want to register model in the
code
so we say okay how do we want to call
our
model that's a penguin classifier clf
and for this we use a little bit lower
api of mlflow which is the mflo client
api
and there we create a registered model
with that model name
um
and i mean i put it in a tri except
because if it already exists it will
complain
but
um yeah so and then basically we know
okay we created a registered model
um has no description so far no versions
and there's a name and no tags
and in the ui
you can now go from experiments to
models and there you see now there's
here penguin clf created you could also
create it here in the ui by clicking on
create model
and we see this has nothing
inside of it so no versions
nothing in staging nothing production
so we want to
change that
so and registering a model is actually
quite simple and again there are two
ways there's always the or probably even
three ways there's also the cli way
um i'm showing you the python api and
then of course there's the ui way
so
you pick a run id that you want to
register so we go to the experiments
and
what do we pick we want this one
probably
so i have this run id
copy this over here
and then we call amberflow register
model
point to the specific model file in the
in the artifact store basically like
runs
and the name where we want to register
it which is basically the name of the
model we created
we registered
and we run this
okay so it tries
to say okay probably didn't exist so we
check okay it says all right already
exists so i create a new version
and it created version one of the
penguins classifier
and we can see again the results so
this is basically the
basically the model that is create a
model version is created
in no stage
has a name it's linked to this run id
this is the path to the artifact store
like to the modern artifact store
it's ready had not no text no status
messages so far and version one
so if we go here we can
we can see it here so there's now one
version and this is it
one thing to notice is now in the
experiment ui you also see that this
model
is now
part of a registered model of version
one
and so it's not psychic learn anymore so
it's that now
a registered model with a version
um
that's
that and you can go back here to the run
and see the run
and the results
parameters and metrics and stuff
good
so
[Music]
next
yes
no that's a unix unix time second since
1970 something
um yeah
so yeah the question to this answer
was
what what these timestamps mean and if
they can be decode like what they are
and their unix time stamps and they
should be here in the ui there should be
proper timestamps
like they should be decoded in the ui
so register is here last modified here
it's just for internal handling
any other questions
please
so the registered model directly
references the picker's model
yes and the run so
the question was
if the registered model already like
directly references the
uh
artifact stored model
the pickle file basically
and yes i mean that's the case it
basically points to the location in the
artifact store and to the specific run
um
yes so the question was if we delete the
runs then the registry is broken yeah it
should not let you delete runs that are
connected to a registered model
and i mean if you delete your database
if you lose your database if you delete
your s3 bucket or whatever file system
of course stuff is lost
yeah
but play around with it that's the time
for breaking things
yeah please
i mean
so the question was if we can enforce or
use some life cycle policy to get use uh
rid of unused models or unused runs
and
so
short questions yes so there is nothing
in place in mfloat to directly say like
i want a life cycle policy
but um like like register model or
create experiment or something
there's a bunch of functions available
i'm just not including them here and the
documentation is a bunch of like delete
run delete run list all runs you can
iterate through runs and check if they
link to something and then you could
delete them automatically so you would
have to write your own script or you an
airflow
node or whatever you you like to enforce
it yourself it i mean mflo basically
gives you like a ui and some conventions
to put things together
and then you can
i would say quite easily
and with a reasonable effort add
functionality as you need it to to make
you happy
um
yeah
so good we have this registered
and
so now we want to serve the model from
the registry
and the steps are basically similar for
different deployment tools some
deployment providers like sagemaker or
something
like aws sagemaker or azure ml have also
python api available and i guess
cubeflow is also something
um that's part of mlflow
but yeah we won't do that here but it is
possible and it's relatively convenient
so what you need to do to run this from
the from the cli is
basically this command as i said we do
amazful model serve
you
tell it where the tracking server lives
as an environment variable here
and
since i didn't list conda in the
installation requirements we use no
conda otherwise it would create a
specific content environment here it
will use pip
you could also use docker here but also
i didn't want anyone to install
like everyone to install docker here
and then you point to the model and the
version of the model you want
and you tell it the port
where it should
serve the model
you can also if you later we will see
transitioning
to stages you could also tell the stage
here
you can tell a diversion or you can tell
the stage
um to deploy so
no right now we can do that right i mean
probably you need to put
pip and run before that
between mlflow and 5000
so
new thing
so
[Music]
so pip and
run
we point to to the the
tracking server again and then we run
this so let's see
and now we say okay it gives us a bit of
information so it says like well
we we deployed with backend python
python function flavor
and then it basically started a scoring
server
um
that's listening on port
4242 conveniently
and now we can
we can use for example crl
to invoke the endpoint and the endpoint
is always
on slash invocations
or we can use the requests python
library
to to
query the endpoint one important thing
to notice if you want to
send
json or something structured data there
it's
most of the time recommended and
necessary to tell
ml flow the mfl endpoint how to decode
your data so here we have
so you pass a format with the content
type and tell it it's a pandas records
which means it should use the pandas
load from records appenders from records
or data frame from records and yeah
something like this to
okay to
load this data into pandas and if we run
this okay we see okay it worked
two thousand at 200 and we get some
predictions
and i mean these are also completely
made up values but you get some
predictions
um
can i jump here in here really quick
because we have three questions from the
online community okay please
and number one is is it possible to lock
the entire pipeline of the model for
example the pre-processing steps
so
if you have a psychic learn pipeline so
yeah the question is still
so if you have a psychic learn pipeline
then it's quite conveniently
the way we did it here
if you have different pre-processing
steps in place you would probably write
a custom model which is basically a
python class that at some point has a
prediction
function
and that can be used there as a python
function i can i can in a second point
to
to the part in the documentation and i
prepared a bit for it so
yeah it's i would recommend it in
general so
um i never used it actually with the
built-in flavors
so i always have like a custom thing
which is not too hard and then you can
really track everything you did
and you can expose also everything you
did and not just have a model and
another thing around it to have a
production ready api kind of
that's that yeah do you have more
questions right yes i have two more but
i think this one lost a little bit of
context
it asks you have to set the environment
variable separately right it's not part
of the command unfortunately doesn't
mention which command
that might refer to
[Music]
this right
yeah i mean there's one
uh environment variable you have to set
the mfl tracking uri
that should be enough to run
everything here but
yeah i'm not sure ask again if you need
more and then question number three also
how to ensure that the model
dependencies of the pipeline are the
same once we serve the model
i mean
i mean i was in the devops talk before
and um
seems not too easy right but
here emma flow tries to do that by
giving you
um
um
pinning
pinning the versions in the model file
so if you go to the model
see here there's a there's a condy yaml
which basically takes all the all the
requirements from your
that are needed to
run the model
and tries to pin them as
as
possible yeah
so that should hopefully
um recreate it possible so it's a bit
you have to be a bit more careful again
if you have a custom model you need to
probably
log your code
with it to have it available in the
environment right you cannot just rely
on the pickle file if you have custom
code
locked but yeah
okay thank you very much i think these
are all questions so far from cool
you had a question
you can also do that there's also um
there's also in the documentation a
large part of like a large section on
how to write your custom deployment
targets
and how to set it up i have not done
that yet i have to say but
should be possible
good so let's
so there's a lot of stuff where you can
deploy that
and probably the final thing we want to
do here is
transition the transition to stages so
if you have a deployment script for
example you at some point so mflow does
not directly deploy stuff you have to
tell it to deploy stuff
and then you have a deployment script
and at this in the script you probably
want to transition the stage right you
i mean here we would jump to just
production but you could also jump to
staging
um it has three environments
uh three stages available staging
production and archived and then there's
also the deleted stage
um
which only shows up and runs i guess so
i mean this is also again with the
client api so transition model version
stage so we reference the model name
which is the registered model name
the version and which stage we want
and there's also again the client has a
bunch of functions or methods
to
to manage these stages i'm only showing
you one
um to see it and then this is the output
and now the mod which is basically a
reference to the model in the registry
and now we see here it's in production
and if we go to
the
ui we see okay version one is in
production now
i mean
here it means nothing right but
it's in production and here probably
doesn't change here now it's still it
still stays mod version one right but if
you go here to the run
now
good so
that's
that's part two i guess we have
done
at four right
quarter past
uh cool very good then we can have a
quick look at some
[Music]
some
tips and tricks i mean it's not too many
so
we can have a look what i also find
interesting um
yeah or more questions
can you say the first part again
ah so if you if you can ah so like the
question was if you can basically have
multiple models at one deployment
endpoint i guess
um
like like here
um
so
you've
not as far as i know so it it in the end
it rely like all mf flow
at least the built-in deployment
tools all
rely on you you point to the amber flow
to the endpoint invocations
um i mean you could have a custom model
that has takes multiple data points and
probably
has different model artifacts inside of
it but that's like a bit of a hack i
guess
so you would probably deploy multiple
models
i have another three questions from the
online oh people bring them on
as a follow-up to one of the previous
questions is it possible to install the
dependencies in runtime for example if
we use model the model in an api
[Music]
i'm not sure what to answer there um
so if you run them with
for example i mean we we
picked here no conda for example
because because installing conda might
be a bit annoying and i didn't want the
additional dependency for the tutorial
but
um
if you want it with without this no
contact for example it would create a
new
content environment for example for
every run
forever every time you call this command
and deployed in this environment for
example you can do the same with a
docker then it creates a new docker
image
for every
time you call this and then starts this
or you can
for example for other tools like if you
want to put it to ecs for example you do
build and push then it creates a docker
container
pushes it to ecs and you can run it from
there for example and then of course it
also installs the dependencies
yeah every time
fresh
hope let's answer the question
we will know in about five minutes when
the next message is in
what's the default strategy to do when
you're serving a model in an api and you
train the model again and wish to switch
the model being served to the new one
i mean that's quite a general question i
guess
okay can you say it again
i'm afraid i can't i already closed
close to you okay sorry so
i mean
i mean
optimally you
it's hard to answer i mean you i would
say you switch for example your docker
container completely you have a
your model return some version
versioning for example could be could be
the model run uri
the run id for example then you can
identify later in your in your where you
store the predictions of your model for
example you can identify where it came
from and you just switch out docker
containers for example um behind your
api and you have a little downtime
probably or you have like some rolling
deployment
depends on what tools you use
yeah hard to answer
maybe someone else knows
so
the question was if you can have
more likes let's say two models in
production and and
split the traffic between them so
so amber flow is not
um
it's not
in place for managing for managing this
kind of deployment i guess you can have
different versions in place
um
and different mods in production but
then you have to do two deployments
right so you cannot do deployed for
these two and split the traffic so
amazon is also not rooting the traffic
you have to say okay i have this
endpoint and it's a singleton endpoint
and you could kind of have two endpoints
but then you would need some solution to
manage how the and the traffic is
distributed i mean sagemaker for example
would do that for you or
azure ml as far as i know would do that
for you it can say like okay i have two
models i give them different weight but
everflow internally cannot do that it
doesn't manage that
as far as i know
and then there's this last question from
from discord
is there a way of decoupling the ml flow
code from the actual model code
so i guess that refers to
to this
part
here i'm not sure what it refers to
to to me the model code and the ammo
flowcode is
reasonably
decoupled
um
so
i mean sure i mean okay i mean
probably it refers to to this mix enough
like you have mflow calls and model and
cyclone and other stuff calls in between
and you probably don't want that um so i
mean sure what you could do
and i've seen that is
you for example
build that as a decorator or you just
start to run here create and collect all
your stuff that you want to track
in between in some dictionary or
something and in the end log it
onto mlflow or you could create
decorator and i've seen that
that you put around your training
function and all outputs are basically
locked
um
to ammo flow
i'm not sure what i prefer
um
so you can do that you can put you can
track it at any point i mean you just
need to i mean this is also only one way
to tell emma flow where to run and where
to store stuff
i mean you could also directly call up
an old run for example with the with the
client api and say like well i add some
more information there i have some new
new information
that would be part parts for example of
the tips and tricks for example you
could have like a model integration test
at some point where i said like well i i
just um started like like here i run run
something at the end i loaded it i
probably have some other python code
around i run that
and if that passes some specific
requirements with some test data i add
some information to the repositor to the
model itself like here you could for
example add a tag right tag
and then if you want for example to move
it to a stage or to move it to a model
version this tag needs to be there you
could check that
so
um
i mean briefly here you can for example
list the experiments and then you can
set a tag to a specific run id after the
model was run this is in the tips and
tricks notebook for example
and i forgot to
to
repeat the question i guess
sorry
yeah
i only understood half the question
sadly
so i guess the question so i'm still 100
sure i guess the question was if we can
lock the scikit-learn parameters from
the context
somehow right
yeah
yeah for for a lot of like like if for a
lot of um built-in flavors there is
actually called a function auto log
if you go to mflow
documentation
we can
whatever
there is
so
and there is
all kinds of built-in
built-in functionality so there's the
automatic logging for all kinds of
libraries
and there we would basically only call
emma flow
where is it
oh yeah you would basically just
essentially auto log and then it would
discover everything right
um i mean i don't i mean it might be
beneficial i don't like it too much
because it i i need flexibility and that
would be also my answer to
would you
decouple the
machine learning code and the tracking
code more and
again i'm not i mean you can do it and
i've seen it but i don't like it too
much because i know want to know where
thing came from that i'm tracking and
not
hide it further
mature if it gets super complicated then
you can think about doing something
no i mean there is so the question was
if there's user and permission
management and the short answer is no i
mean you know you can see here which
user did something so that is locked but
it's only your file system like your
local
running user
so there's no permission management
stuff yeah
you for right first like leftover
no it uses that so the question was if
it uses an sqli database on the server
here
i mean i mean so esco lightest so
i'm not sure for the reason but ml flow
requires to have this deployment and
registry stuff working requires database
back-end i guess because of the file
paths
um and the question here was like if i
would really use an sqli database in the
production setting on some servers
somewhere right but of course so you can
do that i mean usually that only stores
the parameters right so it's not super
critical data and it's not doesn't have
to be performant in general
so if you just have a backup for that
thing in place yeah that's something i
would do but you could also point it to
a redshift if you want to spend money
um or you can run your own postgres or
all kinds of different stuff so there's
if you if you look here there's a lot of
um different scenarios also available or
like
described here how you can store
artifacts and runs right and i mean i
grabbed stuff from here but
there's all kinds of different setups
that you can do live with proxy with
different remote hosts
so
yeah there
the model is always saved in the
artifact host
or the artifact store so
i mean
in our case it's now in the local file
system right but you could also point it
to
for example
an s
free bucket for example let's see if i
find it quickly
okay i don't find it quickly but
it's probably also in this notebook
quite at the beginning so i mean you can
you could i mean i would just dump it to
i mean you just dump it to some s3
bucket and then you have the run id and
then whatever artifacts you have there
like oh basically experiment id run id
um and then all artifacts to this run
basically like you would have here in
the
um ammo runs right then you have
experiment id number one then you have
different ones and you see okay here's
artifacts in
in there
and that's then how it's stored
yeah
maybe one
okay we continue with this question
quickly
um i mean
so i guess one benefit of mlflow is you
can start quite
the question was um there's a lot of a
lot of built-in cloud provider solutions
for this um ml ops or management of
models and stuff and training
why and when
would would you use the ml flow then
so
i the largest benefit to me from airflow
is you can start small really small like
a single single developer on local
machine and have a benefit and then from
there move on to
to
some platform and you can customize a
lot
and then some cloud providers only give
you parts of the equation right and you
can use for example emma float apache
together so that's for example something
i do
um or what is what i commonly did so far
it's like have for example
sagemaker handling all the the really
deployment stuff i don't care i don't
want to have handled security stuff blah
blah and points someone else can take
care of that
infrastructure
but
mflow for for tracking experiments and
then it's isolated in sagemaker for
example you p can piece together things
if you want um but sure i mean if you
have a cloud provider and you know hey i
have like a 50 or whatever a data
science team
and right now i want to do xyz then you
can probably just start using a cloud
provider i mean there's different
solutions for that i mean i guess all
the dvc is quite nice right
um i haven't worked much with it should
offer parts of this functionality so
ammo flow is far from the only tool for
that
just some tool that was around when i
started looking for such a tool and then
i started using it and now i'm a bit
stuck with that
because it's convenient when you know
a bit what you're doing
but yeah there are different tools and
other stuff i mean you could also do the
weights and biases or something for for
these kind of things right
so i'm afraid we have to come to an end
maybe we end on a
very brief question from our online
community
which is about the integration with
continuous integration and deployment
tools
how well does it integrate
i mean that's quite a general question i
mean depends on what you
do and how well you
and how much effort you want to put in
managing your environment
i mean if you can get your whatever
bitbucket github gitlab runner for
example to integrate with to interact
with a remote server outside of github
and you get your your company's it
department or security department to
allow that
then they integrate probably quite
nicely
um yeah depends i mean in the in the aws
environment you probably can do stuff
with code build and without leaving the
the ecosystem which is will probably
make some people happy um specifically
aws
yeah but yeah i don't i don't know too
much about that to be honest
okay then thank you very much for
enlightening tutorial
yeah thank you
you